was bait car remember that [ __ ] show
where they would just have a car
basically like
running like a bmw in the middle of the
project with the door open
it was playing jay-z yeah it was like
you know there's like a hot pizza in it
you know yeah definitely a cooler full
of beer
it's like oh what do you mean all this
i'll get in it and drive away
there was like a um parole officer in
the back
afghan pop-up yeah it was crazy that
yeah that show was crazy
how was that legal and that was
everything it's like they should have
called it entrapment yeah
every episode was just a running car in
the projects let's see what happens
let's see what happens now someone's
gonna steal a car i don't want spoiler
alert you
you know i don't have to tune in it's
not must-see tv it's not like our roster
reacher gonna get back together
this guy's gonna steal this car what do
you wanna see
what's your crime of choice you think if
you have one man oh mine
yeah definitely embezzlement is it
really oh for sure for sure
i love like the whole like heist movie
stuff like i would think like anything
like get weird like
like could you have done it in the pa
nowadays it's tougher there's not even
much cash sitting around
yeah you need you need cash like if i
could go back in time and be any like
sort of like pull off any big schemes
would definitely be like a
nice bank robbery in like the early 30s
yeah yeah
would you be already working at the bank
because i could see you having that
that vest yeah like
right in the little changing 30 cents
back like that [ __ ]
i'm all about that i'm all about that
life you know
1930s teller right here man yeah i'd be
a bank manager to get the inside scoop
you know
that kind of deal then i'd make them
fire me in a fantastic way and then i
think i would know the lay of the land
and i would get my
you know my next door neighbor involved
yeah i'd probably blackmail somebody
blackmail could be fun too
yeah those are the good old days we
could do a crime yeah before we had dna
remember oh
man dna ruined crime for everybody
stupid science getting in the way
yeah back in the day when you had to
actually do some detective work you know
because now every murder you watch the
cops have no idea until
seven years later when they can afford
the dna test that's right it's like i'm
never gonna know uh anything
about like that stupid swab your mouth
thing did you do that like the 23 and me
yeah i did it we could mail it in yeah
[ __ ] up you did it i [ __ ] up
what wait what'd you do i want to go to
jail for it anyway i'm not going to be
one of these people who's going to do a
crime and like
hide all the time i'm going to go to
jail that's what i like about you yeah
thank you you're right
you're right up front all the time oh
yeah i'd rather go and get my time done
and get out yeah
when you said i did it wrong i thought
you maybe i was like what'd you swab
that you did it wrong
i [ __ ] up like what'd you do i don't
remember exactly i think i did the
mountain
good evening good afternoon and other
times
thanks for watching that video you just
saw i mean it was okay
but the next video you can watch could
be way better what if you watch a video
right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one
watch this one watch this one watch this
one
ah